[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشهري
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور تاتيكم من عده مدن
اوكرانيه على واقع كثير من التطورات خصوصا
في بخوه لكن اخرها ما اعلن منذ قليل نقلا
عن الشرطه الاوكرانيه العثور على اكبر
مقبره جماعيه في خارطه
وايضا هذه الصور لمؤشر الداون جونز ومشهد
الاقتصاد الامريكي بعد الازمه التي عصفت
ببعض البنوك وعلى راسها سيليكون فالي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في تطور يفتح الباب امام التصعيد اسرائيل
ترفع التعتيم الاعلاميه عما سمته حدثا
امنيا خطيرا على الحدود مع لبنان وتقول
انها قتلت شخصا بعد تسلله من الحدود
وتنفيذه تفجيرا بعبوه الناسفه جنوب حيفا
الاثنين الماضي الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه
يحقق في مسؤوليه حزب الله اللبناني ورئيس
الاركان يدعو للاستعداد لمواجهه محتمله
على جبهات عده بينها ايران
وزيرا دفاع روسيا والولايات المتحده
يجريان اتصالا هاتفيا بعد تحطم المسيره
الامريكيه في البحر الاسود يقول ان على
الولايات المتحده ادراك خطوره تطور
الحوادث الى مواجهه
يصف تصرف الطائرات الروسيه بالمتهور وغير
الامن وفي السباق نحو الحطام بيانات
ملاحيه تظهر تمشيط الطائرات غربيه منطقه
البحر الاسود بعد حديث روسي عن توفر
الامكانات لانتشال بقايا المسيره
مع استمرار المعارك لحسم باخ موت
مواصله الدفاع عن المدينه
وميليشيار تقول انها تعزز مواقعها شماليها
ورئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه يصف التقدم
الروسي في المدينه بالتكتيكي والمكلف وغير
الفعال ووسائل اعلام تنقل عن مصادر مطلعه
موافقه اسرائيل على بيع اوكرانيا انظمه
تشويش قد تساعدها في مواجهه المسيرات
حزام الامن البحري مناورات روسيه صينيه
ايرانيه في بحر العرب الجيش الايراني يقول
انها ستتواصل خمسه ايام ووزاره الدفاع
السينيه تقول ان التدريبات ستساعد في
تعميق التعاون الفعلي بين القوات البحريه
للدول المشتركه
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا كشف اسرائيل ان قوه عسكريه
قتلت شخصا تسلل من لبنان ونفذ التفجير
بعبوه الناسفه عند مفترق جدو جنوب حيفا
الاثنين الماضي لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما
هي انعكاسات اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي قتلى
متسلل مسلح قديمه من لبنان النتيجه جاءت
على النحو
نحو 49% راوا انه حدث عابر بينما توقع نحو
51% تصعيدا وتطورا في المواجهه
طبعا هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
في تفاصيل ما اعلن اذا يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الحادثه وقع الاثنين الماضي
على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه وانه
قتل شخصا تسلل وذلك بحسب الروايه
الاسرائيليه من الاراضي اللبنانيه وانه
مسؤول عن تنفيذ تفجير وقع في مفترق بجده
جنوب حيفاء صباح الاثنين
وفيما كشفه بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
تحقيقا جاريا بشان مسؤوليه حزب الله
اللبنانيه عن العمليه هذا الكشف تزامن مع
حديث لرئيسه هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه عن
ضروره الاستعداد لحدث على جبهات عده تشمل
ايران
48 ساعه من الخوف والترقب عاشتها اسرائيل
في انتظار تفاصيل ما وصف بحدث امني خطير
على الجبهه الشماليه كانت البدايه من
تفجير عبوه الناسفه في حيفا صباح الاثنين
الماضي اسفر عن اصابه اسرائيليين بجروح
خطيره لتبدا تحقيقات بشان من وضع العبوه
عند مفترق مجد جنوب حيفا اظهرت التحقيقات
ان العبوات التي انفجرت عند المفترق ليست
كتلك التي يستخدمها الفلسطينيون ما اشرع
الباب لاحتمال شبه مؤكد ان عمليه مفترق
مجد نفذت بايااد من خارج اسرائيل وبعد
تكتم وتعتيم اعلامي طويل رفعت الرقابه
العسكريه الحظر عن تفاصيل الحدث الامني
وفقا لروايه الجيش الاسرائيلي فان منافذ
عمليه ماجده تسلل من نقطه غير معلومه
عابره للحدود من لبنان الى شمال اسرائيل
استقل المنفذ سياره وقطع سبعين كيلو مترا
حتى الى جنوب حيفا حيث زرع العبوه الناسفه
عند مفترق ماجده ثم استقل سياره عائدا الى
الحدود الاسرائيليه مع لبنان يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان عمليات تفتيش واسعه قادت
الى الوصول للسياره التي استقلها المنفذ
طوقت قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي المنفذه في
بلده يعاره حيث كان يحمل حزام الناسفا
معدا للتفجير ما استدعى اطلاق النار عليه
وقتله ورغم الحظر الخانق الذي فرضته
المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه خلال اليومين
الماضيين على الحادثه تسرب هذا المقطع
لعمليه القبض على السائق الذي اقل منفذ
عمليه مجدو المؤكد ان هذا الحدث لم ينتهي
بقتل المنفذ بل انه صفعه لاجهزه الامن
والمخابرات داخل اسرائيل
فمنفذ هجوم مجد ظل طليقا يتجول فوق
الاراضي الاسرائيليه ليومين اما السؤال
الاهم فهو كيف عبر الحدود الى داخل
اسرائيل روايات كثيره عده يمكن ان تقال
الاعلام الاسرائيلي تحدث مثلا عن تسلل
منفذ هجوم مجد عبر نفق من جنوب لبنان الى
شمال اسرائيل وان صدقت هذه الروايه فهي
مسار حرج للجيش الاسرائيلي الذي اعلن
نهايه 2018 تدمير سته انفاق هجوميه لحزب
الله تخترق الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انه يحقق في
مسؤوليه حزب الله عن هذه العمليه
والاستنفار الامني الذي اربك اجهزه الامن
والمخابرات في اسرائيل لن ينتهي بمعرفه ما
حدث بل سيبقى الى حين الرد على من يقف
وراء الاختراق الامني الخطير وفق وصف
الجيش الاسرائيلي
وينضم الان الينا من الناصره مراسلون
الياس كرام ومن الناقوره على الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه مدير مكتب الجزيره
مازن ابراهيم الياس ومازن اهلا بكم ما
ابدا معك الياس بعد اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن تفاصيل العمليه هل استجد
شيء
بالامكان القول بان اسرائيل الان في معضله
حقيقيه ازاء هذا الحدث الامني الكبير
والخطير كما تصفه وهي في معضله لانها ان
لم ترد على هذه العمليه خاصه وان تبين ان
حزب الله ضالعا فيها سواء كان ذلك من قريب
ومن بعيد فان ذلك سوف يؤدي الى التاكل
ردها واذا ردت على هذه العمليه بطريقه ما
ان كانت عسكريه او غير ذلك فانها ربما تجر
الوضع على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه
الى مواجهه شامله وهذا ربما ما يفسر ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ابقى على قواته على اهبه
الاستعداد القصوى وهذا ايضا دليل على ان
الايام القادمه قد تحمل معها على الاقل
توترا وترقبا وتاهبا على طول الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه نشير هنا الى ان
مصدر سياسي اسرائيلي قال للقناه الرابعه
عشره
الاسرائيليه في هذا السياق تحديدا وهي
قناه يمينيه
قال بانه اذا تبين ان حزب الله ضالع في
هذه العمليه فان اسرائيل حتما سوف ترد وان
ردها سوف يكون قاسيا الواضح بان التعتيم
الاعلامي الذي فرضته الرقابه العسكريه
بطلب من المستوى السياسي في اسرائيل ربما
مكن الحكومه الاسرائيليه من خفض حده
التصعيد على الاقل في الساعات 48 الماضيه
وربما التخفيف من الضغوط التي ربما كان
الشارع الاسرائيلي قد يمارسها على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ويطالبها بالرد من ناحيه اخرى
اسرائيل عمليا بقتلها لمنفذ هذه العمليه
هي قتلت عمليا مصدر المعلومات الرئيسي
وبالتالي اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه امامها
عصف ذهني كبير من اجل تركيب الصوره
بكاملها والوصول الى كبد الحقيقه ومعرفه
ما الذي حصل بالتمام هنا لكي اسئله كثيره
ما زالت مفتوحه وتنتظر اجابات كيف وصل
منفذ العمليه الى عمق 70 كيلومترا ونفذ
العمليه في جنوب
حيفا في منطقه مجده هل اخترق السياج
الامني ام انه استخدم نفقا لم يكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعرف بوجوده لماذا اختار ان
يصل الى العمق الاسرائيلي وامامه الكثير
من المدن والبلدات الاسرائيليه القريبه من
الحدود التي كان بامكانه ان ينفذ فيها
عمليته التفجيريه لماذا عاد بعد العمليه
التفجيريه الى مسجد في مجدو الى الحدود مع
لبنان رغم انه كان بحوزته اسلحه كما يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي وحزام ناسف وكان بامكانه
ان ينفذ عمليه اخرى لماذا اختار ان يعود
الى الحدود مره اخرى اسئله كثيره من هذا
القبيل ايضا عمليه قتله تثير جدلا كبيرا
لماذا قتل وفيما ان السائق اعتقل الذي
اقله بطبيعه الحال ولم يقتل وافرج عنه بعد
ساعات قليله من التحقيق الى كثيره تحتاج
الى اجابه هل هناك اي اجابات من الجانب
اللبناني مازن هل صدر اي رد فعل على هذا
الاتهام الاسرائيلي
في الواقع ليله الجانب اللبناني حتى هذه
اللحظه يبدو غير معنيا بتقديم اي اجابه
على ما تطرحه على الروايه الاسرائيليه على
نقيض من ذلك ما يبدو وكانه قرع لطبول
الحرب عند الجبهه الشماليه من قبل اسرائيل
يتم النظر اليه هنا في بيروت بانه بمثابه
قنبله دوخانيه الهدف منها التستر والتعميه
على ازمه داخليه يعيشها نتنياهو وبالتالي
لجوئه الى هذا الحدث الامني الذي حصل في
تلك المنطقه
لمحاوله اطفاء نوع من التحميه على الجبهه
الشماليه لعلها تعرف الانظار باتجاه هذه
الجبل للجبهه الداخليه التي واجه فيها
ازمه كبيره هكذا هي القراءه اليوم في
بيروت من هذه الزاويه يتم النظر الى كل
هذه التطورات وما تم الاعلان عنه من قبل
اسرائيل وكتم المعلومات لفتره زمنيه من
بعد ذلك اعلانها والبدء بالحديث عن جبهه
مواجهات ستفتح وصولا الى ايران وبالتالي
ضمن هذا الصعيد الذي ترى فيه بيروت بانه
تصعيد كلامي كبير على مستوى
الدعايه الاسرائيليه انما قد لا يؤدي الى
تدهور الاوضاع هنا عند الجبهه الجنوبيه
نظرا لان لا احد يريد او يرغب بان تفتح
هذه الجبهه لاسيما بعدما تم ترسيم الحدود
خلال الفتره الماضيه خلال اكتوبر الماضي
والجميع يستعد لاستخراج وتصدير الغاز
والنفط من هذه المنطقه وبالتالي هنالك
جمله اسئله ايضا تطرح في بيروت عن تفاصيل
هذه العمليه التي كشفت عنها اسرائيل والتي
تبدو وفق السيناريوهات المطروحه بنسبه
اليوم لقراءه حزب الله لهذه السيناريوهات
بانها لا يمكن ان يعتمد هكذا تكتيك عسكري
كي يتسلل احد العناصر من هنا من بيروت من
جنوب لبنان وصولا الى تلك المنطقه التي
تبعد 70 كم في العمق الاسرائيلي والقيام
بوضع عبوه تستهدف مواطنا وفلسطينيا ويعود
ادراجه كيقتل هنا عند الحدود لان حزب الله
عندما ينفذ عمليات فانه يعتمد التكتيكات
مختلفه هذا ما رصدناه خلال السنوات
الماضيه عندما كان يرد على الغارات التي
كانت تستهدفه في العمق السوري كان ينفذ
عمليات عسكريه واضحه ضد الاهداف
الاسرائيليه عند طول الخط الحدودي ايضا
كان يدخل الطائرات المسيره وهذا ما
شاهدناه عندما ارسل مسيرات الى فوق حق
الكاريش خلال الاشهر الماضيه وبالتالي
ليلى النظره في بيروت تختلف وهنالك ضروري
من الاشاره بان حتى اسرائيل حتى الان لن
تجزم بشكل حاسب وقاطع بين حزب الله هو من
يقف وراء ارسال هذا الرجل الى تلك المنطقه
وبالتالي السيناريوهات مفتوحه وهي تذكر
ايضا بانه لربما احد فلسطيني الداخل هو من
نفذ هذه العمليه في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي
لن يكن يتسلل من لبنان او في حال بعجله
اذا كان يتسلم من لبنان فان هنالك بعض
الفصائل الفلسطينيه التي من الممكن ان
تكون ارسلت بعض الشبان الى تلك المنطقه
اذا النظره في لبنان تختلف ولكن ايضا
اسئله عديده تنتظر اجابات اشكرك مدير مكتب
الجزيره مازن ابراهيم من الناقوره على
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه وشكرا جزيلا
لالياس كرام من الناصره
ومحاوله للحصول على بعض الاجابات ينضم
الينا من الناصره الدكتور سليم بريك استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي دكتور سليم اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
كيف يمكن ان نتوقع ان يتطور هذا الحدث بين
الصمت اللبناني كما سمعناه ايضا بين تضارب
التصريحات بالجانب الاسرائيلي وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه نقلت ان وزير الدفاع
يقول شيء والجيش يقول شيء بشان الرد
مساء الخير واضح بانه هذا الحدث هو حدث لا
يرتقي لا يكون حدث استراتيجي يغير قواعد
اللعبه بين اسرائيل ولبنان ولكن اكيد هذا
حدث فارق اولا بمبنى هذه القنبله التي تم
العبوه الناسفه التي تم استعمالها
تركيبتها القضيه الثانيه طبعا لماذا اختير
هذا المكان بالذات هل هذا كان هدفه
التغطيه وكان العمليه قامت مثلا من جنين
هل سيتم استعمال مثل هذه العبوات الناسفه
في المستقبل تطويرها في المناطق المحتله
يعني عده اسئله لا توجد عليها اجوبه
نستطيع ان نقسم الموضوع لثلاث مستويات
المستوى الاول الاستراتيجي وهنا الخلاف
بين الجيش وبين
القياده
السياسيه رئيس الحكومه هو وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي طبعا قبل الحديث عن هذا
الموضوع يجب
الوصول الى كل المعلومات
وهنا نحن لا نعرف الكثير من الاسئله لا
نعرف ماذا الاجوبه عليها على ما يبدو انه
اخترق الحدود من لبنان فاذا اين كان الجيش
ولماذا الجيش لم يكتشف هذا الموضوع طبعا
منفذ العمليه كان في منطقه اسرائيل شمال
اسرائيل حوالي 48 ساعه على الاقل فاذا
ماذا حدث هناك لماذا لم يشعر احد كيف تنقل
في اسرائيل هناك اسئله كثيره هل كانت لهم
مساعده من الداخل من المنطق المحتله مثلا
ثم السؤال المركزي حتى الان حزب الله لم
ياخذ على عاتقهم هذه العمليه فاذا هل حماس
لبنان هو الذي بادر الى هذه العمليه هل هي
عمليه مشتركه هل هناك رساله من حزب الله
بانه نحن نستطيع ان نخترق الحدود
الاسرائيليه وان نصل الى عمق دوله اسرائيل
كل هذه الاسئله طبعا
الجيش الاستخبارات
السياسه الحكومه الجميع ينتظرون اجوبه
دقيقه لكي
يتخذوا قرارات ولكن رغم ان الاجوبه غير
موجوده رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
ضروره الاستعداد للمواجهه على عده جبهات
بين ايران ماذا تقرا في هذا التصريح
نعم هنا في عده اسئله السؤال الاول هل
يحاول حزب الله الان رفع
مستوى او سقف الرضع بينه وبين اسرائيل
لانه هناك قواعد التي تم اتفاق عليها بعد
حرب 2006 وعلى ما يبدو ان حزب الله الان
بعد ان خفا الضغط في سوريا يريد ان يعود
ويتعامل مع الردع امام اسرائيل القضيه
الثانيه طبعا ايران عندها حسابات كثيره
ومحاولات انتقام على كل مقامات باسرائيل
حسب ما يدعى او حسب ما تدعي ايران فاذا
هناك اسباب ايضا ان نقتنع بان حزب الله
ممكن ان يكون وراء هذه العمليه القضيه
الثالثه هو التغيير النوعي هل هذا التغيير
النوعي سيكون فقط في هذه العمليه ام اننا
سنشهد في المستقبل عمليات اخرى قضيه
اضافيه كيف سيؤثر على علاقات اسرائيل
لبنان نحن نذكر بانه قبل عده اشهر تم
اتفاق على كريش
حقل الغاز في في البحر المتوسط
بوسط مفاوضات غير
بواسطه الفرنسيين والامريكيين اذا الان
ماذا سيحدث هل ستتغير كل هذه الامور هل
سندخل في تصعيد مثلا والان امامنا طبعا
رمضان المبارك اسرائيل قلقه جدا مما سيحدث
في الضفه الغربيه والشرقيه القدس والان
توجد هناك اسئله حول امكانيه التصعيد في
الحدود اللبنانيه اذا اسئله كثيره ستبقى
معلقه وفي انتظار الاجابه عليها الدكتور
سليم بريك استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا
لك من النصره
[موسيقى]
لاني لا مشهد التراشق الامريكيه الروسيه
على وقع ما حدث فوق البحر الاسود امس
والحديث عن تحطم المسيره الامريكيه فبعد
اتصال بين وزيرين دفاع موسكو واشنطن قال
الوزير الامريكي انه يجب على روسيا تشغيل
طائراتها باسلوب امن ومهني وكذا ان
الطائرات الامريكيه ستواصل عملها في
الاماكن التي يسمح بها القانون الدولي
مشيرا الى ان الطائرات الروسيه قامت بعمل
متهور وغير مسؤول فوق البحر الاسود حديث
اوستن كان في مؤتمر صحفي شارك فيه رئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
الذي قال ان القوات الامريكيه ستحاول
انتشار بقايا المسيره الامريكيه مرجحا انه
لم يبقى منها ما يمكن استرجاعه
الجانب الامريكي
كان له راي اخر وزير الخارجي ان توني
بلينكن قال ان حادثه المسيره كان متهورا
وغير امن وانه يجب التحقيق بشانه ايضا اما
نظيره الروسي فقد انتقد ما وصفه بالتجاهل
الامريكي المستفز لاغلاق روسيا مناطق من
البحر الاسود قريبه من اوكرانيا امام كل
انواع الطائرات وقال لابروفين تواصل
استفزازاتها كما سماها وان هذه
الاستفزازات محفوفه بمخاطر مواجهه مباشره
بين قوتين نوويتين عالميتين
الامريكيون يتجاهلون تماما واقع انه بعد
بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه اعلن جيشنا
مناطق متاخمه للساحل في البحر الاسود
مناطق ذات وضع محدود لاستخدامها من قبل اي
طائره مثل هذا التجاهل المستفز لهذه
الحقيقه الموضوعيه
يوحي ان الجانب الامريكي يحاول باستمرار
البحث عن نوع من الاستفزاز لتصعيد
المواجهه هذا سيء لانهم اعلنوا باستمرار
انهم قوه مسؤوله لكن الاقوال لا تتطابق مع
الافعال اي حوادث تثير صداما بين قوتين
نوويتين عظمين هما الاكبر في العالم دائما
ما تنطوي على مخاطر جسيمه لا يمكنهم الا
ان يفهموا هذا
هذا واظهرت بيانات ملاحيه تمشيط طائرات
غربيه منطقه البحر الاسود فيما يبدو بحثا
عن الحطام وذلك على الرغم من ان شبكه سي
ان ان نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم انه
تم عن بعد مسح برامج حساسه
بالمسيره قبل سقوطها وقد اثار موضوع
الوصول الى حطام الطائره تساؤلات في ظل
اهتمام روسيا معلن بذلك
وامريكيا بدا متخوفا من ان تقع
التكنولوجيا الحساسه للطائره المسيره في
يد الروس
من يصل اليها اولا هو السؤال الملح بعد ان
سقطت او اسقطت طائره امريكيه مسيره
للاستطلاع من طراز امبيو 9 في البحر
الاسود اشارت مصادر الى ان سقوطها كان على
بعد نحو 70 كيلومترا جنوب غرب شبه جزيره
القرم بعد ان انطلقت من احدى قواعد النيتو
في المنطقه واقتربت من المياه والاجواء
الدوليه
مجلس الامن القومي الروسي نيكولاي
باتروشيف اعتبر انتشار موسكو لحطام
المسيره امرا ضروريا وقال ان لدى بلاده
امكانيات تقنيه الانتشار الحطام وجاء في
تقرير لشبكه
عسكريين امريكيين انه من الواضح ان البيت
الابيض يفضل الا تقع هذه التكنولوجيا
الحساسه في ايدي الكريم شبكه ام بي سي
نيوز الامريكيه نقلت عن خبراء بدا عمليه
استعاده حطام الطائره لكنهم قالوا ان
البحريه الروسيه بامكانها الوصول الى
الحطام قبل اي سفينه امريكيه
فقد تداولت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تسجيلات صوتيه قالت انها لعمليه اطلقتها
القوات الروسيه لاستعاده الطائره التي
يعتقد انها مجهزه بتقنيات تجسس متطوره
عاده وتخضع عمليه الانتشار الى جمله عوامل
وفق خبراء بينها المعاينه اولا ثم تحديد
العمق الذي توجد فيه المسيره واحداثيات
دقيقه للموقع وارسال فريق غطس متخصص كي لا
يتم الاضرار بالطائره ويستهدف البحث
والانتشار بالاساس التاكد ان بقيه المسير
جسما واحدا او سيتعلق الامر بانتشاد اجزاء
المتفرقه وموضع الكاميرات الدقيقه
الموجوده بها يفسر خبراء مصارعه موسكو
لانتشار حطام المسيره لتسجيل ما يمكن وصفه
بالنصر المعنوي ويتحدثون عما يعرف
بالهندسه العكسيه لاعاده الانتاج وهو امر
مستبعد او على الاقل معرفه خصائصها
الدقيقه وماذا التقطت اذا لم تتضرر ولانها
سقطت في البحر الاسود فقد قال وزير الدفاع
التركي بشان امكانيه فتح البحر الاسود
للسفن الحربيه الامريكيه ان تركيا باشرت
اتصالات مستمره مع الاطراف كلها لحل
الازمه وللتذكير فمسيره
متطوره تجعل الجيش الامريكي يعتمد عليها
في العمليات العسكريه وتصل سرعتها الى نحو
370 كيلومترا في الساعه لطائره متعدده
المهام المزوده بمعدات رصد بالليزر قدره
على اطلاق سته صواريخ وقنابل بدقه عاليه
وبوسعها ان تحلق لمسافه تزيد عن 1500 كم
او لمده تصل الى اكثر من 30 ساعه وبما
انها طائره من دون طيار فمن الطبيعي ان
فريقا على الارض هو الذي يتحكم بعملها
[موسيقى]
ومعنى الان من نيو جوزي او بالاحرى اولا
من موسكو الكسندر ارتامانو فالخبير
العسكري والمختص في شؤون النيتو ومن
نيوجيرسي الدكتور مايكل بويل استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه
روتبرز ومؤلف كتاب عصر المسيرات كيف ستغير
تكنولوجيا المسيرات الحرب والسلم اهلا
بكما في الحساد وابدا معك سيد الكساندر
ارثمنوف في البدايه هل يمكن لهذه المواجهه
الاخيره باستهداف الطائرات ومسيرات ان
تتطور الى مواجهه بين الطرفين ابعد بكثير
ام ستصبح
النسيان بعد فتره بسيطه من الان
الواقع الان
الاداره الامريكيه قامت باعلان
واعترفوا ان هذا الحادث مع المسيره هو
حادث غير متعمد من الطرف الروسي
الفيدراليه وكان هناك مصطلحات دبلوماسيه
ان هذه اعمال لم تكن متعمده اي انها بمحضى
الصدفه وانا ارى ان الاداره الامريكيه غير
مهتمه بتطوير هذه الحادثه الى اي مواجهات
وكذلك السفير الروسي في الولايات المتحده
انطونيوس قال ان روسيا لا تريد اي مواجهات
باي شكل من الاشكال والان نرى ان جميع رحل
الطائرات المسيره الامريكيه قد توقفت في
محيط القرم لذلك الاوضاع تعود الى
الاوضاع العاديه ولن يكون هناك اي تصعيد
الطرفين هل يمكن القول الان ان انتشال
حطام
المسيره اصبح اهم بكثير من المعلومات التي
جمعتها وربما حتى اهم من اسقاطها يعني
سمعنا ما قاله سكرتير الامن القومي الروسي
روسيا لديها القدره ولديها الامكانات
للوصول الى الحطام ولكن هل هي معنيه بذلك
وما درجه اهميته
يد مشرود
من جديد ان روسيا تستطيع
استخراج هذا هذه الطائره المحطمه ولدينا
الامكانيات والاليات حتى في هذا الوسط
الصعب ولكن هذا لن يكون له اي ظل
دبلوماسي لا من اطراف الروسي ولا الامريكي
لدينا مثل قديم مع تركيا تعلمون في اطار
النزاع السوري تركيا قصفت ودمرت الطائره
الروسيه وقتل الطيار ولم تقم روسيا
بجعل الحادث اكثر صعوبه في العلاقات بينها
وبين تركيا في هذه الحاله في حاله المسيره
لم يتضرر اي شخص حي لذلك لن يكون هناك اي
مواجهات حتى ولو
استطعنا ان نجد هذه الطائره
واذهب
لضيفي من
الدكتور مايكل بويل هل
تشعر وانا هناك سباق ربما على الحطام الان
يعني روسيا تقول انها تستطيع ان تصل لم
تفعل والجانب الامريكي
يصعب الامر يقول ان الحطام على
عمق كبير ولا يمكن الوصول اليه ماذا تقرا
في الثنايا
اعتقد ان هناك سؤال مفتوح لا ندري هل يمكن
انتشال الحطامه لا اعتقد ان
الحطاب وقع في منطقه عميقه في البحر وتنتج
يقول انه استطاع محو المعلومات الحساسه
قبل سقوطها ثم سقطت المسيره في البحر اذا
لا يبدو ان هناك من المعلومات الحساسه ما
بقي ليجعل من
المفيد الوصول اليها لكن روسيا طبعا تحاول
اظهار نفسها بانها ستحقق نصا معنويا رغم
انني لا ارى ايه اهميه عسكريه لذلك هو ليس
سباقا بقدر ما هو نوع من التنافس على
احراز بعض النقاط
ممكن
هذا
النموذج من المسيرات يسمى بام كي تسعى وهو
موجود منذ اكثر من عقد من الزمان
وتبقى التطورت نماذج منه طبعا لا استطيع
ان اتخيل بان
المخابرات الروسيه قد استطعت من الان ان
تقيم اهميه هذه المسيره او ما يبقى منها
لا اعتقد ان
الاهميه هنا تكمن في اي معلومات عسكريه
الولايات المتحده تحققها وتعطيها الى
اوكرانيا هذا هو الامر المهم من وجهه نظر
استخباريه لهذا السبب الولايات المتحده
تقول ليس من الممكن الحصول عليها لانه قد
تم محوها على العموم هناك خبر اريد فقط
ابقي معي ضيفي الكريمين هناك خبر نقلا عن
موقع اكسيوس مصادر مطلعه تقول ان اسرائيل
وافقت مؤخرا على تراخيص لبيع محتمل لانظمه
تشويش مضاده يمكن ان تساعد اوكرانيا في
مواجهه المسيرات الايرانيه حسب هذا الموقع
ابلغ وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه الرئيس
الاوكراني بالموافقه على التراخيص خلال
زيارته لكياف منتصف فبراير الماضي كما زار
وفد من وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه اسرائيل
مؤخرا للحصول على عرض تقديمي بشانه انظمه
مواجهه المسيرات ولم يتم التوقيع على اي
اتفاق حتى الان بهذا الشان ونقلت كذلك عن
مسؤولين اسرائيليين قولهم ان انظمه
التشويش الدفاعيه ولا تستخدم اي نيران حيه
يمكن ان تقتل الجنود الروس
واعود لضيفي سيد الكسندر
تمنوف
اولا كيف لروسيا ان تتعامل مع هذا الخبر
اني اعتقد ان روسيا تنظر لهذا الخبر
بحزن لان من وجهه نظر روسيا الغريب ان
تقوم دوله تتضرر من الهولوكوز اذا اخذنا
اليهود الاسرائيليين لديهم منظمه يد يا شم
ان هذه المنظمه التي حارب حاربت ان زيا
لانهم ضحايا الهروكوس فمن الغريب ان
يدعموا نظام النادي في كييف الذي لا يخفي
نازيته ان قوات ازوف الممنوعه في اوروبا
دليل على هذا من الغريب ان يدعموا
اوكرانيا واعتقد ان هذا الاتفاق لن يتم
حتى اليوم الحكومه الاسرائيليه ترفض ان
يكون لها اي شراكه من هذا النوع مع النظام
في كييفا اعتقد ان هذا سوف
يجعل اسرائيل تسقط في اعين العالم
سيد مايكل بويل طبعا فقط نؤكد ان صح هذا
الخبر وان تم ما مدى فعاليه انظمه التشويش
هذه ان حصلت عليها اوكرانيا
بعض النقاط الاول انا انا لا اعتقد ان
هناك اي تناقض النظام الاوكراني ليس نظاما
النازيا ولا يوجد اي شيء من هذا القبيل
ولا تشابه ابدا في
بين النظام الاوكراني ان يشبه النظام
الناتى في المانيا لهذا السبب الحكومه
الاسرائيلي ستجرى حساباتها من منظور مختلف
لكن اذا ما اخذنا بعين الاعتبار ان روسيا
تعتمد على مسيارات ايرانيه فان اسرائيل
سوف تعطي هذه المعدات اذا ما اعطتها فان
دوافعها ربما هي معرفه المزيد عن المسيرات
الايرانيه اما الى اي مدى ستكون فعاله
ستكون فعاله من وجهه نظر ان والتكنولوجيا
الاسرائيليه في مجال التعرضي للمسيارات
متقدم لكن الامر في النهايه لن يغير من
مسترياتي الحرب لان اوكرانيا من الان
القادره على اسقاطها العديده من هذه
السياره ستكون ذا تاثير لكنها لم تغير من
مسار الحرب اشكرك الدكتور مايكل بويل
استاذ العلوم السياسيه ومؤلف كتاب عصر
المسيرات كيف ستغير تكنولوجيا المسيرات
الحرب والسلم وهو في صلب هذا الموضوع شكرا
جزيلا من لك من نيوجيرسي وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من موسكو الكسندر
ثمنه
ضيفنا من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
فيما يتعلق بالتطورات في مدينه ضخمه بعد
ثمانيه اشهر من المحاولات الروسيه للسيطره
على المدينه يقول الرئيس الاوكراني
ان الموقف بات واضحا نحو تعزيز جبهتها
مؤكدا استمرار القتال في المدينه وفي
المقابل تقول ميليشيا فاجنر انها تتقدم
رغم صعوبه الاوضاع وانها تعزز مواقعها
شمالي وشمال غربي المدينه هذا التقدم وصفه
رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكي مارك
ميلي اليوم وصفه بالتكتيكي وغير الفعال
المعارك في بخموت لا تتوقف قريبا هذا ما
كشف عنه اجتماع قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
بالاجماع قررت هذه القياده لاستمرار في
الدفاع عن بخموت قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان
الهدف هو تدمير المهتل
التركيز الاساسي هو في اتجاه خورتيتيسيا
وباخموت هناك موقف عام لدى القياده
العسكريه وهو المضي في هذا الاتجاه لتدمير
المحتل بالطبع نعمل باستمرار على امداد
الجبهه بالذخيره
يرى كثير من الخبراء العسكريين انه لم
يبقى هناك معنى عسكري لاستمرار
الاوكرانيين في الدفاع عن ضخموت التي لا
تكتسي في نظرهم اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره
ولن يغير سقوطها مجرى الحرب
لكن القياده الاوكرانيه وان كانت تعترف
بان خطر محاصره المدينه من كل الجهات يلوح
في الافق فانها تصر على الدفاع عنها ميخيل
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان قوات
بلاده تحارب في ضخمه لان استمرار المعارك
يعوق تحرك افضل وحدات الجيش الروسي ويلحق
بها اضرارا كبيره قبيل الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد قريبا يعترف الطرفان بصعوبه القتال
في بخموت التي تشهد حاليا معارك خنادق
تذكر بالحرب العالميه الاولى
هنا يتم التقدم بيتا بيتا ما يرفع من عدد
القتلى والجرحى في الطرفين رئيس اقليم
دونتسك المعين من قبل روسيا دونيس بوشيرين
قال ان هناك معارك طاحنه من اجل كل متر في
المدينه واضاف ان ما سماه النظام
الاوكراني لا يهتم بعدد القتلى في صفوفه
اما قائد ميليشيا فاغنر الذي تقود قواته
الهجوم الروسي على بخموت فقد قال انه واثق
من ان الاوكرانيين يعدون هجوما مضاده لفك
الحصار الذي اقترب من اكماله على المدينه
[موسيقى]
تقترب معركه بخموت من اكمال شهرها السابع
هي اطول معارك حرب اوكرانيا واكثرها دمويه
بالنسبه للطرفين لم تعد اهدافها تقتصر على
الجانب العسكري تحولت الى رمز للمقاومه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وسقوطها يمكن ان يؤثر
على الروح المعنويه للجنود الاوكرانيين
وقد تتحول الى رمز للانتصار بالنسبه للروس
الذين لم يحققوا نصرا كبيرا منذ منتصف
السنه الماضيه لهذا لا تتوقف المعارك في
ضخمه
في الاستوديو معنا العميد الياس حناء
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لا تتوقف
المعارك بشان ضخمه ولا يتوقف الحديث هناك
اختلاف في داخل كل بلد سواء في اوكرانيا
او في روسيا بين الطرف مثلا في اوكرانيا
يريد ان ينسحب طرب يريد ان يبقى والغلبه
يبدو للطلب الذي يريد ان يبقى ويدافع بشكل
مستميت عن المدينه وفي الجانب الروسي طبعا
التضارب المعروف بين فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه كيف ترى اصطفاف القوى بين
الجانبين بشان هذه المدينه تحديدا وحظوظ
الطرفين في الاستيلاء عليها
بالنسبه للشق الاوكراني
الفريقان يقولان انه الكلفه اصبحت كبيره
كبيره لهدف ليس مهم بالمعنى الاستراتيجي
الكبير ويجب الانسحاب كي لا نخسر النخب
الاساسيه
شق اخر يقول ان المعركه انتقلت من العسكر
الى السياسه ولا نريد ان نعطي الرئيس
بوتين نصرا بمكان ما اليوم الشق الاخر لدى
الروس روسيه او الجيش الروسي هناك خلاف
يعني هناك الجيش الرسمي البحريه المارينز
الروس الذين يقاتلون ولكن العب الاكبر هو
على الذي يريد ان يحقق هدفا معين ليقول
لرئيس بوتين انا موجود ولكن هناك من يحاول
ابشاله في هذه المرحله او استنزافه
للمرحله القادمه يعني تؤكل فاجنر في مخبوط
كي لا تستمر بعدها لان لدى
طموحات سياسيه وهذا ما حذره منه بطريقه
غير مباشره الرئيس بوتين
بصراحه لافت ان هذه المدينه باخمت اللي في
البدايه لم نكن نسمعها ابدا كنا نتحدث عن
ماريوبل وطبعا حديث كبير
الان باخ موت هي في الصداره الكل يتحدث عن
باخت وزير الدفاع الامريكي رئيس الامريكي
طبعا ناهيك عن الطرفين المعنيين اساسا هل
فعلا يمكن القول بطريقه ما انا هذه قد
تكون
الجديده ام هذه مبالغه وكيف تختلف عن
مريوط
مختلفه تماما ماريوبول مدينه كبيره
والمعركه الكبرى حصلت في معمل ازوف ستال
هذا في تلك المنطقه كانت قوات ازوف التي
اتهمها الرئيس بوتين بانها نازيه او
متشدده او مشابه ماريوبول تعطي نظره على
بحر ازوف يعني
استراتيجيه مهمه وهي من ضمن الجسر البري
الذي يربط الخاص بشبه جديد القرن اما
محمود فهي من ضمن خط يبدا من
الى مخموت وبالتالي الى اوغلي دار هذه
المنظار العام ولكن هي بحد ذاتها ليست هذه
الهدف الاستراتيجي المهم وهي مختلفه عن
مدينه كبيره
والجيش كانت نقطه التحول في خساره جيش
المانيا ايضا نعود لكلمه او الحديث عن
القيمه العسكريه مقابل القيمه الرمزيه هنا
ثمانيه اشهر من الصراع على هذه المدينه
التي اطراف عديده تقول ليست مهمه ليست
بتلك القيمه الاستراتيجيه
وهذا ايضا يطرح السؤال من جديد يعني اين
نحن الاستمرار الهجوم الروسي من فاجنر في
مخبوط ولكن حقق الجيش الاوكراني بخركاف
بخرسون النصر يعني المنطقه الوحيده التي
بدات واستمرت فيها الهجومات وكانه اليوم
تريد رئيس بوتين ان يقدم شيء تبدل اربعه
قيادات مهمه في نفس المنطقه ولكن اليوم
عندما نتحدث عن مخمود بالحد الادنى هي
مهمه للجيش الاوكراني كسب الوقت ترك
المساحه فقط كي تاتي العتاد ويستعد الجيش
الاوكراني لحرب قد تعد في المستقبل سنرى
كم سيطول الحديث عن هذه المدينه
سنرى على العموم لسوء الحظ من يسكنها ايضا
الضحايا اكيد الى شكوى في المقام الاول
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
بتزامني مع سياقات تصعيد متعدده عالميا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بدات تدريبات
عسكريه ثلاثيه بين روسيا والصين وايران في
منطقه بحر العرب القوات البحريه في الجيش
الايراني قالت ان المناورات المشتركه تحمل
اسم حزام الامن البحري وستتواصل على مدى
خمسه ايام اما وزاره الدفاع الصينيه فقالت
ان التدريبات ستساعد في تعميق التعاون
الفعلي بين القوات البحريه للدول المشاركه
المناورات الروسيه الصينيه الايرانيه
المشتركه والسياق الذي تاتي به هو الموضوع
الذي سنتناوله بشكل اوسع بعد قليل في فقره
في المتابعه
اما الان الى باكستان التي رفضت محكمه
اسلام اباد العليا فيها طلب فريق الدفاع
عن رئيس الحكومه المقال من منصبه عمران
خان وذلك لاعفائه من الوثول امام محكمه
ابتدائيه تنظر في تهمه سوءه التصرفه
بهدايا قيمه قدمت له من رؤساء دول الشرطه
تفرد طوقا امنيا حول الحي السكني الذي
يقطنه عمرونان عمران خان عفوا في مدينه
لاهور عاصمه اقليم الفنجاب بعد اشتباكات
مع انصاره
نظر التوتر مستمره في محيط مسكن رئيس
الحكومه الباكستانيه السابق في لاهور
اصرار الشرطه على تسليم عمران خان مذكره
استدعاء للمحكمه تسبب في احتكاك بين
الشرطه وانصاري رئيس الوزراء المقال الذي
يخشى اتباعه ما يعتبرونها مكيده لاعتقاله
وتغييبه عن المشهد السياسي
[تصفيق]
لمحاوله تجنب اي مصادمات بين اتباع
والشرطه حاولت التقدم بتعهد رسميا لفريق
الشرطه الذي حاول اعتقالي بانني سامثل
امام القضاء يوم الثامن عشر من مارس
الجاري غير ان الشرطه رفضت علنا تسلم
التعهد وهو التصرف مخالف للقانون
لاهور عاصمه اقليم البنجاب الذي يستعد
لخوض انتخابات لعضويه البرلمان المحلي
شهدت اغلاقا لكل الطرق المؤديه الى مسكن
عمران خان بشاحنات استاجرتها الحكومه للحد
من حركه التنقل
منذ الليله الماضيه لم نتناول اي طعام
الكل يشتمنا لقد تضررت شاحنه كثيرا ولم
اتمكن من ابعادها وقت المصادمات فالحكومه
هنا استاجرت من الشاحنه واخذت مني
مفاتيحها
اليوم يعتبر من الايام السيئه فلاسباب
سياسيه يعاني الناس وسؤاله هو ما الخطا
الذي ارتكبناه البعض لديهم اسباب قاهره
وصعبه ومع ذلك لا يستمع رجال شرطه لاي
مراشده
امام القضاء الذي ينظر في قضايا رفعت ضد
عمران خان وضعت تفاصيل الخلاف الحالي
فطالب القضاء الشرطه بتاجيل محاوله اعتقال
خان عده ساعات ليبقى اصل الخلاف بين
الطرفين قائما ولا سيما بشان موعد تنظيم
انتخابات عامه في كل ارجاء باكستان
صدامات الشوارع واغلاق الطرق ما هي الا
ملامحه للخلاف السياسي بل والالصراع على
السلطه الذي يستمر في باكستان منذ اشهر
عده ويزداد خطوره كلما تصاعد الاستقطاب
الشعبي
عبد الرحمن مطر الجزيره لهون
[موسيقى]
لن نعود الى موضوع المناورات العسكريه
المشتركه بين ايران وروسيا والصين
لاستضاح جغرافيه تلك المناورات واهميتها
فضلا عن سياقها المناورات التي بدات
الاربعاء تشارك فيها قوات بحريه من الدول
الثلاث وتحمل اسم حزام الامن البحري
وتستغرق خمسه ايام
منطقه العمليات التدريبيه تمتد على مساحه
شاسعه من شمال المحيط الهندي حتى بحر
العرب وصولا الى بحر عمان بالقرب من مضيق
هرمز الاستراتيجيه وفق بيان لوزاره الدفاع
السينيه فان المدمره الصينيه الصاروخيه
التي تعمل بالصواريخ الموجهه تشارك في هذه
المناورات كما اوضح البيان ان هدف
التدريبات هو تطوير التعاون بين القوات
البحريه للدول المشاركه وتعزيز الاستعداد
المشترك لضمان الامن البحري وترسيخ السلام
والاستقرار الاقليميين
المناورات تجري في ظل توتر شديد بين
العواصم الثلاثه طهران وبيجين وموسكو
والغرب لاسيما الولايات المتحده من جهه
اخرى
طبعا سبق لروسيا والصين وايران في السنوات
القليله الماضيه ان اجرت مناورات بحريه
مشتركه في المحيطين الهندي والاطلسي وبحر
عمان كذلك في مطلع عام 2022 اجرت قوات
بحريه من الدول الثلاث مناورات مشتركه
شمالي المحيط الهندي وخليج عمان الهدف كان
وقتها والذي اعلن هو ضمان سلامه الشحن
الدولي وتبادل الخبرات والمعلومات في
مجالات البحث والانقاذ
في فبراير عام 2021
المناورات مناورات حزام الامن البحري جرت
بين قطع بحريه ايرانيه واخرى روسيه بينها
البارجه وذلك تحت شعار التعاون الجماعي في
البحر من اجل سلامه التجاره البحريه
الدول الثلاث في ديسمبر عام 2019
نفذت وعلى مدى اربعه ايام مناورات هي
الاولى من نوعها شاركت فيها مجموعه من
السفن الحربيه الروسيه التابعه لاسطول بحر
البلطيق سنناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من
اوسلو الدكتور جلان ديسن استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه ساوث ايست في النرويج
اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور ديسم فيها الحصاد
طبعا
السؤال عن هذه المناورات هل وراءها مصالح
انيه قد تتلاشى مع الوقت ام اننا فعلا
نرى تحالف من نوع ما في طور التشكيل
[موسيقى]
هذا ليس تحالفا بالمعنى الرسمي لان ذلك
الى درجه كبيره ستكون له
الردود ومردودات ونتاج عكسيه لان روسيا
اصبحت
حليفا رسميا للصين فانها ستبعد الهند عنها
واذا ما اصبحت
روسيا
حليفه للصين الصين هنا ستدخل في مشاكل مع
الغرب وكذلك ايران مع الدول العربيه هم لا
يريدون ان
يحرض طرف ضدهم على سبيل المثال اذا ما
ارادت روسيا والصين ان تكون لها علاقات
فهم يريدون لعلاقات من تكون طيبه مع
الجميع مع الدول العربيه وحتى مع اسرائيل
اذا هو تعاون مضاد للهيمنه ان صح التعبير
لان الصين تشعر انها مهدده من المتحده
والولايات المتحده تشن حربا بالوكاله ضد
روسيا في اوكرانيا وكذلك المتحده كثيرا ما
تهدد ايران وهذا ليس سرا قد تندلع حرب
بينهما لهذا السبب ليس غريبا لهذه القوى
الثلاث ان تتعاون عسكريا نعم لكل دوله من
هذه الدول الثلاث جبهه تفتحها مع دوله
اخرى وعلى مستويات مختلفه لذلك عندما تصر
هذه الدول على ان هذا امر عادي هذه
المناورات عاديه وتحصل بين هذه الدول لكن
في ظلمه يجري حاليا
على عده جبهات هل هناك سياق اخر تقرا فيه
عدا عن سلامه البحار والملاحه البحريه
نعم نعم
من حيث
النتائج العمليه هي محاوله للمرهنه عن قوه
مشتركه تجمع هذه
البلدان ضد المتحده
تهدده هذه البلدان الثلاثه تتعاون في
بينها اما من الناحيه العسكريه طبعا هناك
مبدا اخر وهو مبدا اقتصادي في الحقيقه وهو
التكامل الاسيوي
الاوروبي
والبلدان المنضويه تحت لوائه تحاول تطوير
تكنولوجاتها الخاصه هناك ايضا ممرات
ومبادره الطريق والحزام التعامل بعملاتهم
الخاصه استخدام انظمه تسديد دفعات ماليه
خارج الاطار المعروف هذه البلدان
ان تتكامل مع
بعضها البعض اللي تحظى باستقلاليه اكبر عن
النظام الاقتصادي لامريكا الذي كثيرا ما
تفرضه امريكا فرضا لهذا السبب هذه
المناورات هي وجه اخر من اوجه التعاون
التي لا تسعى لتقويض الامن الامريكي بقدر
ما تحاول ان تقوض من الهيمنه الامبراطوريه
الامريكيه طيب اذا بغض النظر عن الاهداف
فاذا كانت تحاول ان تقوض من الهيمنه كما
تقول الامريكيه ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه من
الولايات المتحده في المقابل
المتحده تواجه معضله لانه المتحده لا
تستطيع ان ترمي بكل ثقلها في الحرب مع
روسيا لان ذلك سيضعفها امام الصينيين
والايرانيين
المتحده لم يمكنها ان تدخل في حرب ضد
ايران كذلك لان ذلك
سيضعفها امام الصين وروسيا قد تقف الى
جانب ايران وهكذا اذا من خلال اجراء مثل
هذا التعاون العسكري هذه البلدان
تقلل من قدره امريكا شن حرب ضد اي منها في
الحقيقه اذا لا احد يعتبر ان هذه البلدان
ستدخل في حرب امريكا ولكن هذا من ناحيه
منطقيه هي تعاون وترتيب في الحقيقه وايضا
القصد منه هو ان تكون لدى هذا البلدان
الثلاث استقلاليه اكثر وسيطر اكثر على قوه
العسكريه لان البحريه الامريكيه تهددهم
باستمرار
في النرويج شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا لك وبهذا ننهي جوله الحصاد الليله
شكرا لكم على المتابعه وتصبحون على الف
خير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]